what's up free Jack nation we're gonna
watch today from cosmic wonder x-men MCU
debut lineup possibly revealed and I
want to thank today's sponsor which is
the ridge now if you've seen any of our
you know sponsored segments before you
will know that we try to make all these
jokes and everything while also
delivering on all the necessary talking
points but I just wanted to come from
the heart today I don't know if Ridge is
gonna be cool with the way I'm doing
this I'm just gonna be they sent me over
this titanium matte black wallet right
effing love write genuinely great new
blood I found myself like at the grocery
store just recently shopping with my
girlfriend and then as I pay I'm like
this is a great keeps things organized
the money strap is great all my wallets
fall apart and I'm like this age is it
looks cool got me to be more efficient
cuz I'm like I only really need my debit
card triple-a card
what are the talking points of cards
cuz your choices strap or money clip for
cash alright 5d blocking so your
information is more than 30 colors and
designs to choose from including carbon
fiber and burnt titanium thirty thousand
five star reviews I went over to see Dan
and Elissa to drop something off are my
neighbors they'd worked with rich to do
I was like did you guys get hurt like
you know are they great great so join
the ridge vision if you use our link in
the description box save 10% off cludes
free worldwide shipping and returns
Father's Day is coming up your daddy
will love it you'll love it
your dad's like mine he's got a wallet
the size of a burger change his life
haha
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
lender where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we're going to talk about one
of our favorite topics and that is of
course the x-men making their Marvel
Cinematic Universe debut we're all
waiting for the x-men to debut and it
looks like they're going to start to
make their appearances starting in phase
four and then come together in an
Avengers like film except only it will
be the x-men film and today we have a
new report about a possible lineup that
Marvel is considering for the x-men in
the MCU and not only don't whine oh
you're some of the x-men might actually
come from so we'll break it down in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay if I don't
like her leading to the MCU and so you
can access some of that voice Rosalie I
mean I'm a little bit more after the
original x-men might to wonders main
room record so we all know that the
x-men get to be you the question is when
and also who are the ones that we're
going to see first well a recent report
from Mikey Sutton name-drop several
mutants that we can expect to see in the
MCU some familiar some not so familiar
so we'll break down what this report
said it says that Marvel Studios has
plans for the x-men are in the earliest
stages of development the mutants are
indeed coming to the MCU and will be
introduced Avenger style and other care
cries or Iraq according to Mikey
settings inside sources they are
currently looking at the initial lineup
of the x-men to include Cyclops Marvel
Girl Thunderbird Nightcrawler Sunfire
havoc and storm who is going to be from
Wakanda according to this report once an
all-new married for so long with the
x-men the president of Marvel Studios is
looking at focusing on the team as a
school with some students joining
Professor X on missions while others
still studying and training essentially
a Hogwarts for mutants now although this
is in very early development and there
is no concrete plans right now no script
written or any
the next part could be a potential
spoiler so proceed at your own will the
series boiler warning what Professor
Xavier school does and what the x-men do
is brought to surface win spoiler alert
Thunderbird is killed during a trip to
krakoa like he says that no scripts have
been written as of yet there is only
brainstorming and discussions at this
point but this is reportedly where they
are at third meetings likewise we have a
surprise that no videos has already
begun presents what they plan to do with
the x-men Marvel has the next five years
mapped out on which movies they're going
to do and which characters they're going
to introduce into the image the gorge
meaning they have over 10 years as well
in fact Kevin Feige movies in Hamburg
new guidance at San Diego comic-con of
2019 so we know that they are definitely
already brainstorming on what to do with
the x-men now in this report there are
three main things that we need to focus
on and the first one is the lineup
Cyclops
Marvel Girl Thunderbird Nightcrawler is
about havoc and storm you now it's
important to note that these are not
going to be the only x-men introduced in
the MCU at this time some classes report
doesn't mention Professor Xavier and his
school and if we have his school in the
MCU that means we're going to have many
many different mutants what this lineup
implies is that rumbling in the backers
that are actually going to make up the
x-men team the team that goes out and
does missions together just as the
report stated some are going to go out
and some are going to stay and study and
the lineup is quite Gowanus and a little
bit unexpected but that's what Kevin
Feige is going to want to do he's going
to bring in some of the lesser-known
x-men and bring them to the big screen
and some of the bigger ones are
unfortunately going to take a seat back
for a little bit so the Fox accident
bill the height man post credit scene
reports mrs. dumb says that magneto will
eventually come and be the villain but
also will eventually go on to lead the
x-men against Doctor Doom but in this
report he does state that this is going
to be several several years down the
road most likely not until the next
Avengers in game level event and that's
because most of the movies that Fox did
concerning the x-men had magneto in it
his character and other main characters
need to cool down a bit until they come
into the MCU however they are keeping
characters like psycho
is the second thing that this report
talks about that is really really big
because her story is going to tie the
MCU together in a really big way this
report says that storm is going to be
from what Conda this is something that
may be shown here black panther the
relationship between storm and black
panther and warm or T'Challa and Aurora
both actually meet when they are young
in fact their children when they meet
for the very first time
Aurora was in Cairo and her parents were
killed which left her alone wandering
the desert she eventually decides to go
back to her mother's homeland in Kenya
but while on her travels she comes
across to Chawla who was being kidnapped
at the time using her weather
controlling powers she rescues him and
he has an instant chemistry becoming
friends and a little bit more actually
they work very well Panther would go on
to join the Avengers and storm would go
on to join the x-men after going
separate ways their lives kept them busy
but they would bump into each other here
and there and so eventually black
panther decided that it was time for
them to get married in 2006 in Black
Panther vol 4 number 14 and 15 to Chawla
took to a knee and proposed to storm now
storm resisted at first
expressing her heartbreak from them
being separated as kids but ultimately
would agree and the two of them would go
on to get married now this is the
extremely important part to the MCU and
here's why the wedding was an extremely
big deal at the time in the comics they
actually got married during the civil
war ceasefire event but it was such a
big deal that the x-men do's and the
Fantastic this me even showed up to
watch them get married this could be an
event in which we see the Avengers the
x-men and the Fantastic Four all
together for the very first time in the
MCU now I know a lot of people outside
of the church the Toni Stargate Kia
premiere
they're sitting in orab main and at the
time when Black Panther came out Marvel
actually didn't own the rights for the
Fox x-men characters yet but they do
know and now that they buy they might
have different notions on the rights
Nakia may show up again but also she may
be gone and storm could come into play
key enhancer tops wasn't that movie they
had mice maybe they're actually ever
want to get a divorce
and this divorce was a pretty big deal
because it was caused by the Avengers
versus the x-men five of the x-men
including name war would get possessed
by the Phoenix force and wall possessed
by the Phoenix force Namor practically
destroyed Wakanda now since storm would
have a recliners and then he decided
with the x-men after Wakanda was
destroyed she returned to Wakanda to
tell T'Challa that she was sorry
but he told her that he annulled the
wedding and he was no longer her husband
this is a big deal because there's been
reports that the ultimate goal for the
x-men entering the MCU is going to be an
Avengers vs. x-men film and if Marvel's
way with the story storm being in the
MCO it's going to be a very big deal and
it sounds like she's going to be part of
the original MCU x-men team now the
third thing that's very important to
talk about is Weapon X now Weapon X
refers to a program the Super Soldier
program but also very rain Weapon X
weapon ten is Wolverine now you may have
cut my video that I did not too long in
Jassa force access program the Weapon X
program has plus they're both
interchangeable but what it really is is
the Super Soldier program Wolverine is
weapon King Captain America was weapon
number one he was the first experiment
for the program and the Incredible Hulk
Thunderbolt Ross said that he basically
restarted the weapons Plus program and
that's what he's going to be doing in
phase four when we start off with Black
Widow leading into the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Thunderbolt Ross is going
to be looking for new serum we know that
he's going to be looking for the serum
in Black Widow and then in the falconeer
soldier we know that the mayor Captain
America is going to be given a new super
soldier serum but the new serum that US
agent John Walker is going to be given
is going to be used to control his
mind and this is what the Weapon X
program is going to do create
essentially super soldiers super people
and be able to control them now since we
have a Weapon X program that means that
Wolverine is going to be a part of that
program according to this report which
probably means that Wolverine has been
in the MCU for some time now he's been a
project and experiment of the Weapon X
program but about a lot of the main
weapon number one and it's your son's
cap or America the First Avenger there
are definitely more than ten Weapon X
experiments already in the MCU and fun
fact Deadpool is part of the Weapon X
program as well and right now of course
we know that more that is working on
another Deadpool film so according to
this report we are getting the x-men in
the MCU soon with a new lineup
Wolverine of course eventually making
his way and Deadpool of course as a
geographer friends where do you think
about this report what do you think
about the new lineup what do you think
about storm being from Lokhande and do
you think she's going to have a
relationship with Black Panther and what
do you think about Wolverine coming in
with the Weapon X program let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
for live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof okay all right some solid
information here potentially my main
takeaway with this out of the tube
things being reported on here that I
feel like are most likely going to occur
Aurora Monroe being from Wakanda and
having a love relationship of some kind
maybe not married but some kind of
romantic relationship to say the least
with two tala then the Weapon X program
slowly being introduced as he warns a
hundred percent right that coincides
with the Super Soldier Serum from the
First Avenger and then of course the no
teasing general Thunderbolt Ross being
in Black Widow and hims trying to you
know find a better type of juice for
this to not only have superpowers would
also use mind control because clearly
when you're not able to control
them things get outta hand those are the
two ingredients that I see I could
almost say certainly you know I'd be
very very very surprised especially if
they don't use storm is a romantic
entanglement with T'Challa considering
the comic story considering that we've
had black panther what I like about this
initial tease of a possible lineup this
lineup has a mix of characters that
we've seen in the x-men movies already
who didn't really get do service hey you
know what happens to it so when I guess
everyone can agree that Cyclops really
got the short end of the stick yeah and
then yeah havoc is in x-men first class
and Days of Future past and then you
have Nightcrawler
who had a lot of screen time in x2
whatever some type of treatment in
Nabokov Marvel Girl I mean three
characters now you got Captain Marvel
Miss Marvel Marvel Corolla like let's
get more let's get Lady Marvel dr.
Marvel professor and then on top of that
and Captain Marvel you got Marvel Mr
Zuma to me the whole thing with
Thunderbird being killed just just
sounds like brain storming at this point
specific detailed plot points are not
anything I'm gonna believe right now but
there's things here where I'm like oh no
they're definitely gonna work with that
like Weapon X just makes sense by the
time you get to like it's the natural
trajectory of this situation after
having Captain America black panther
Ororo that makes sense
x-men vs. Avengers having another type
of civil war movie but really doing it
with expert like that it goes my nating
it like it's and Avengers and not a
Captain America see that goes a hundred
percent in tune with my original initial
idea that I wanted bro and you're
introducing the mutants cuz everyone so
far has gotten their power unless you're
like some God or some other planet most
of the characters that we've gotten have
gotten their powers you know you know a
gamma rays radioactive spider by another
side of your serum whereas this the the
mutants these are people who are born in
earth with these abilities are they a
threat so I don't know if
that's the path they're gonna go down
but the idea of x-men versus Avengers is
very exciting than coming to a
resolution where they do team-up I love
that that would be awesome yeah totally
I got a lot of thoughts John sorry about
a lot of things I'm very invested in
keeping alive because know this does
sound like a really exciting plan and
especially I mean yeah these are vague
details and we don't know how many of
them are gonna materialize but
especially if that's the plan for like
the end of a decade or something like
that is to build up the x-men and that
finally have this conflict between them
and the Avengers and then have that lead
into another New Age like I like the
concept of having a massive conflict
that's even more conflicting than having
just a big bad villain yeah they're
characters on both sides we were
probably gonna love and care about we
loved the x-men we loved the Avengers
like we're gonna have a lot of internal
conflict and I feel like that is a great
way to cap off a phase of capital - haha
knock knock with the venom and really
punctuate the introduction and really
make it a huge event and yeah I love
that idea and also I really enjoy the
like hidden history stuff where like it
makes a lot of sense that if you know
during World War two they were
experimenting with Super Soldier Serum
and Captain America's weapon one you
know yeah and the background all this
time they've been working and you know
that even if this wasn't the plan from
the very beginning there's gonna be
stuff that they can go in and show you
like oh this had context you weren't
aware of get ready for more Easter Egg
ring having storm you know having like a
strong it's not really my place to
comment this I guess but like having a
strong black female character to be such
a crucial role seems like a really cool
thing you know especially especially on
the heels of Captain Karen Karen Marvel
but you know like like for you know
that's ground not broken yet you know so
at then that could also be really cool
to see a hundred percent man I bet in
Black Panther 2 we're gonna see Aurora
would not be surprised and I'm really
hoping they do I've been imagine that in
the trailer any time in that trailer and
that movie that you see whether you're
just gonna like this or Oh is she making
retros there's a storm coming
oh and then like some villain characters
not gonna know what they mean by that
but then Aurora was gonna show up I've
never been more excited for storm to be
a romantic interest of man hey maybe
there's gonna be a stormy movie where
Scala is the romantic interest who needs
safe Finn I don't know the full ins and
out details of the other report which
I'm now seeing here because you're
clever to do a video that the original
x-men oh we've heard this talk before
the original x-men some of them might be
appearing which i think could make sense
for the hand me off and the transition
and the reason why is not just cuz of
MCU but more importantly dead bolt if I
they're gonna keep the same Deadpool
around the fact that he was birthed the
Ryan Reynolds version initially in the
x-men franchise from Fox and they've
already had that big thing about Patrick
Stewart having talks with Kevin Feige
about possibly trying to like help hand
off this franchise in some way yeah I
wouldn't be surprised the other thing
I'll had on Cyclops
I am hoping because Cyclops in the
comics you know of the unit that the
x-men was the leader in the field it
would be cool if we really do get
Cyclops introduced when they were doing
the official x-men debut of him being
the leader I know some people might be
like white male lead I respect that it's
fair it's nice to watch them die on
screen what do you think about this
report leave your thoughts down below
one of these nifty roots and there's a
ridge comm slash reject nation only
while I've ever talked about and like
ever in life like you should see this
book subscribe click that out it you
would you just will not know how cool
this isn't to you're holding one of your
hand from on education plus they're so
fun to play with yeah like they got this
nifty little stick school the whip out
top
phanom subscriber edge excavation work
there are patrons who are pledge for
deleted takes my haven't seen stuff they
also get a name call out so want to
shout out a few of these guys out right
now happy smith burns or live you chase
gardener Deonte waa k tongue punch fart
box i got a block in Sotelo Javier Gomez
Jen Smith justin modern kala waters
Katie waters Lucas Romero
nobody February night on Oh PJ endemic
rooby-roo narc a Ryan Beatty doth Yoda
order 66 shifty crane Spencer thanks
guys nope we're not done yet
Brianna Davidson James no briga Josh
Philip J Smith jr. thank you thank you
guys so much for pledget or patreon and
showing your support hopefully you guys
have been enjoying yourselves over there
much love check us on patreon and also
right now maybe for watch this video you
can see that you have the option to
donate to the bail project I've been
raising some money here and there for it
it's gonna be on our channel for a while
so thank you guys so much
see you guys soon